if you think about having your own
executive assistant a great executive
assistant is prepared to answer all of
your questions and that's where a lot of
the assistants live right now they're
responsive to you they know the answers
they come back an even better assistant
starts anticipating your needs and
that's where we go with things like the
calendar or we're proactive email
recommendation you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen
heusinger
[Music]
the entertainment industry has long
offered as a vision of the perfect
personal assistant one that not only
meets our stated needs but anticipates
needs we didn't even know we had with
these uber assistance from the
preternaturally prescient radar O'Reilly
in the TV show mash to Tony Stark's
digital no and do it all Jarvis in Iron
Man have always lived in the realm of
fiction or science fiction that could
all change if dr. Paul Bennett has
anything to say about it as principal
researcher and the research manager of
the information and data scientist group
of Microsoft Research he and his team
are working to make machines calendar
and email aware moving intelligent
assistants into the realm of science and
onto your workstation today dr. Bennett
brings us up to speed on the science of
contextual intelligence assistance
explains how what we think our machines
can do actually shapes what we expect
them to do and shares how current
research and machine learning and data
science is helping machines reason on
our behalf in the quest to help us find
the right information effortlessly that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Paul Bennett welcome to the podcast
thank you you're a principal researcher
and you're the research manager for
information in data Sciences at
Microsoft Research so you were at least
two hats maybe more yes tell us more
generally then specifically right now
what you do for a living what big
problems are you trying to solve what
gets you up in the morning within the
information in data sciences group we
think about two things first off
information science is about how people
work with and use information in every
aspect of their lives
data science we think about how do we
analyze the data and behavioral traces
we have from people interacting with
data how can we predict their actions
how can we understand what they're
trying to do what we try to do in the
group is actually bring these two
together and understand how people are
working with information how their
behavioral traces say what they're doing
and what they'd like to do and what
software may not even support them in
doing right now that they'd like to do
even better and so you know really one
of the things I think about at a very
high level of what the group does it's
about taking science fiction and making
it reality
so things that you've seen in movies
that you know 15 20 years ago you said
are not possible first off it's about
making those real and then it's about
envisioning the future and laying the
groundwork for how we get to the science
fiction of the future before we get into
the meat of the interview I want to set
the stage by talking a little bit about
recommendation engines writ large it's
sort of a huge part of our life now and
part of the science and we humans seem
seriously invested in developing tools
that will predict our next movie our
next purchase our next turn our next
relationship so I'd love to get your
take what's our core problem here and
making choices and what are researchers
doing about it right well let me unpack
that a little cuz I think you addressed
two different things in there
one is predicting what actions you might
take another is helping people make
decisions and they're actually two
interesting parts that come in to
artificial intelligence in terms of
recommendation the variety of
recommendation engines that have been
developed you're right haven't
things like advertising or selling you
products even going back to my days as
an undergraduate my first project was
actually on content-based recommendation
engines turns out looking back in this
time I was actually writing a web
crawler just scrape Amazon and recommend
books this was back in 97 and 98 when
Amazon was developing their own
recommendation engine at the same time
at the point of time then you know that
seemed very novel because people hadn't
thought of it applied to any task now
people have applied it to a variety of
things to sell you products but the next
question is you know for intelligence
even when we interact with people you're
thinking about what's going to happen
next how will they react to what you're
going to say you're trying to predict
the future and in some sense that's what
recommendation engines are about can we
predict the future and actually guess
what your next action will be but more
importantly and this comes to the
decision-making question often the
challenges you don't know all the
possibilities hmm and when people are
trying to interact with a set of items
or a set of possibilities they don't
know all the different capabilities that
are out there so an example of this you
know just from search engine point of
view if you went and searched for a
flight on a search engine and said you
want to fly from Seattle to Austin and
it came back to you with a single result
at your price preferences at the single
best time and showed you this one result
the question is are you happy and if you
stop and think for a while but most
people come to the conclusion of this no
I'm not happy and the reason is you
don't know what else is possible and
that's where decision-making comes in
decision-making is not only about
finding what matches your interest it's
about knowing what the other
possibilities are and that this is a
good decision for you to go forward with
and so when we think about presenting
people with information we have to give
them enough supporting information that
they understand where they're going from
there I made a note of a statement I
read in a blog on this topic that email
and calendar recommendations are under
explored in AI research so what was the
aha moment or inflection point where you
decided to do an AI research project to
recommend emails instead of shoes to me
so I think there were a couple of small
moments leading up to things one was
exactly looking to this question of how
people make decisions
what supporting information they need
but then we were doing work specifically
trying to understand where the gaps are
an intelligent assistance of when you
interact with a person what types of
common sense does the person have that
the system is lacking and one of the key
conclusions that we came to was that it
was lacking a lot of information about
context and their variety of things that
go into context but some of the key
variables are time people and what it's
about if I know when something is going
to happen and where you think it's going
to happen if I know the people that are
involved and I know what it's about
those things always exist with email and
with calendars or nearly always
sometimes you have very useless
descriptions of calendar items like sync
or talk but usually think emails do you
get uh it's frightening actually but you
know they were just creating it because
it was in the path of communications of
what they're sharing but the information
that it gives the system than to reason
on their behalf and actually help them
proactively that just offered a huge
opportunity reason on their behalf
that's such a big statement can machines
do that absolutely in very small limited
ways right now and of course what we do
in research is push that boundary even
further but you know when I think about
reasoning on someone's behalf what I
think about is first off you want to be
able to predict what they're going to
need and help them out so if you think
about having you know your own executive
assistant a great executive assistant is
prepared to answer all of your questions
and that's where a lot of the assistants
live right now they're responsive to you
they know the answers they come back an
even better assistant starts
anticipating your needs and that's where
we go with things like the calendar or
we're proactive email recommendation
which is I have this meeting I didn't
actually remember what information was
relevant you were able to determine it
and you were able to predict I was going
to search for this and instead of
wasting my time during the meeting boom
it's just there but then when you really
talked about reasoning on someone's
behalf you start anticipating what are
they going to wish they would have
thought of even after this event where
they came to realize they missed an
opportunity the things that you could
have actually put in there so for
example someone sends me a design
document for some other project doesn't
seem relevant at the time I kind of
ignore it go on with things I have some
other planning meeting for a new project
completely different turns out that that
other design document that I ignored
actually has relevant information worst
yet it's going to create a blocking
situation six months down the line I
have all the right information at my
hands but of course I didn't have the
time and at the time that I received the
first document there was no reason to
think that it was relevant and when you
talk about reasoning on someone's behalf
it's about saying look that information
is there you already have access to it
can we bring that to your attention
actually say hey maybe there's a little
part here that if you dig into can
prevent huge problems in the future
[Music]
so I'm intrigued by the technical
underpinnings and research methods that
might help people like me find as you
phrase it the right information
effortlessly take us into the technical
weeds for a minute
are you using existing methodologies and
new areas or are there some fundamental
explorations in ml methods yes so we
make use of both and we also even go
beyond that within the group we try to
first take an HDI perspective and say if
we were just try to identify what it is
that people need sometimes how they
interact with the system is heavily
influenced by its current capabilities
hmm and so how do you even get after
what they would use if those
capabilities were there or what those
needs are
so for example coming back to this
question I mentioned about time and not
understanding time we said what is it
that people want a system to understand
in terms of time and so we said well
what would it be like if you interacted
with another person so we can go out and
do surveys like that the problem is
there's all sorts of biases to this and
we say what other types of data are
available so here we had email as a huge
opportunity where you're communicating
with another person so we can actually
look at how you communicate time to
another person and what types of
language do you use as opposed to when
you go and set a reminder on you know
whatever intelligent assistant use right
now
you constrain your language because you
think the system is only capable of
certain types of things and so here's
the interesting thing when you go to an
intelligent assistant the first thing
that they want to do when you tell them
something is say what time should I
remind you and it's just this problem
which is I don't know what time and so
the interesting part of this is that we
can actually capture even this kind of
soft information so that we can come
back to you proactively and it turns out
as you get near that point in time you
can often resolve that further more
interestingly if you actually do
interviews which we followed up from
looking at how people communicated an
email in this way it's not just about
that item turns out when you made that
note you probably were doing something
else and your first goal was actually
take the note quickly let me continue to
focus on this item right and so that's
one of the things that some of the
researchers in our group look at is how
do we allow people to focus and
in the moment of what they're doing and
realized that what they may currently be
trying to take a quick note on or do
something else is not actually the key
thing so that's a set of looking from a
very user facing perspective
understanding where the gaps are now
let's talk predictively what are we
trying to do in terms of prediction so
there we have information traces that we
can work with so for example do you
interact with certain types of meetings
in different ways
you send a meeting invite out to
somebody you may reference different
links in it have different attachments
those are all indications of what's
relevant to that meeting and so that
gives you an opportunity to
automatically say here are some examples
of some things that are relevant to this
meeting right then we can look across
all of your meetings emails and
documents and say can we predict on a
regular basis then what is relevant and
so there we come with typical machine
learning techniques where you can start
with very simple techniques like simple
linear logistic regression you can move
on to more complicated techniques
nonlinear methods like greet and boost
the decision trees neural networks it
turns out that in this space the key
challenges though are not so much the
architecture of the model that you're
looking at but how you deal with the
privacy challenges hmm which is very
very again different than things like
advertising and selling you books in
that case everybody is buying the same
books in this case only you have access
to your information which means the
traces that we learn from are only
relevant to you and how we think about
how we generalize across users in ways
versus within a particular user our key
challenges yeah so I'm gonna come back
to the what keeps you up at night and
what are your challenges with privacy a
little bit later in our interview but
I'm hearing two kinds of research going
on one is the user research which is
super important to find out what the
needs are and what the pain points are
and then you're over here on algorithms
and machine learning and the deep
technical weeds of how you take what
you've learned and make a machine be
able to do it yes that's right so part
of it is HCI or human-computer
interaction focus and even within that
field there are huge challenges in
understanding the biases that you deal
with when you try to elicit from people
what their preferences are how they'd
interact with things but there's also
actually an interesting part that's in
between - that connects them so hmm if
you look at a current system again how
you express the
a reminder to an assistant to give you a
certain time you constrained yourself
based on what they expect it and we see
the same thing in every single system so
for example in search engines people
don't type questions that look like a
question quite often for two reasons
first off typing it takes a while but
there's a second reason that's more
interesting
they don't actually issue those queries
because they don't expect the system to
answer them because they know from
experience that those don't lead to
success and so as we add the
capabilities that the systems are
capable of answering those kind of
questions there's challenges getting
people to use them and to actually you
know teach them the behavior it's all
about what if what if something
different would have happened and so we
see the same thing in any given system
what if we would have given you a
different set of documents and said
these were relevant to this meeting
would you have interacted with one of
these or not and so there's a line of
research within the group looking at
counterfactual or causal reasoning that
tries to say okay this is the data we
have but what we want a reason about is
the system we're going to deploy which
is going to behave differently and how
you're going to react to that so how do
we take those past behavioral traces and
deal with the different biases that are
introduced in terms of how you reacted
because of that system as opposed to how
you will react to the new system so how
are you doing that so there are an
interesting set of techniques and this
is again you know new novel techniques
being developed as well
some of the simplest methods look at
actually doing small amounts of
randomization in terms of minor things
so if you think about the order of
documents you're presented if you add
just the slight amount of randomization
so that you don't put them in order of
your predicted relevance but a slightly
different order
you're now actually able to reason over
a broader set of orders that you didn't
put in front of people right and even
small tweaks like that allow you to make
changes now one of the interesting
challenges is where we made progress
deal with very limited situations like
that rankings an item from a small set
of items but as we go in more and more
to rich interfaces there are all sorts
of questions of how does the
presentation affect things so even
simple things like email email when you
do a search may look like a ranking of
items but then it turns out there are
conversations these conversations can be
collapsed or not they can have different
types of energy
mark up all of these effects your
likelihood of interacting with those
items based on more attentional factors
but that influence is the data that we
learned from and so being able to
separate out how your attention
influences your interaction versus what
we really want to ask pain the relevance
and pertinence of the information to you
in order to update the models is one of
those key challenges you have to be
willing to kind of understand that there
may be a suite of different things that
are most appropriate to this situation
as well as being willing to push on the
boundaries and develop new techniques
when appropriate and finding out where
you can actually deal with these
different kinds of challenges by adding
a slight amount of noise to the process
or even showing and you know in other
cases we've done research where we
looked at and said how much can we
introduce randomization without creating
an experience that you'd hate right
because you can imagine that you
actually went into a restaurant to look
at a meal I could put in front of you
five choices that you really liked or I
could add a random choice just to learn
about what you might like that you
didn't know that you liked right if you
might be willing to tolerate that one
out of five now you walk in and you have
five random choices in front of you and
a horrible dinner I may have learned a
lot about you but I can't also you know
at the same time I can't run that risk
and so being able to understand the
limits of how we can do that online
exploration but also sometimes we can't
always do online exploration we have
just what we've observed in the past and
so there we try to identify what are
natural experiments where there's sort
of small amounts of variation due to
random differences in the system a lot
of times we have distributed systems in
the cloud where things are returned
slightly differently because of latency
and those offer natural experiments that
allow you to say can I learn from what
just happened to be random chance and
better predict the future and a lot of
it comes down to when you learn a model
that is influenced by these presentation
or selection biases that happen you
deploy this and then what you actually
find out is it doesn't work and so it's
a false start and you may repeat and
repeat and repeat and so when you learn
from the logs to more effectively
estimate what will happen once you
deploy it it's also about rolling out
innovation to our customers much more
quickly
efficiency is a huge thing in computer
science research making us more
efficient and when I talked to you
before you said it's not specific enough
you know efficiency is a step on the
path of where we want to go it's
certainly not the angle ultimately
intelligence is about changing outcomes
for people giving them capabilities they
wouldn't have otherwise had or allowing
them to essentially be augmented by the
system and so when I say that what I
mean is that when we make intelligent
predictions for people we assume that
there has to be some reason for them to
select what we've put in front of them
the first initial case is usually in
terms of efficiency so for example you
know if I'm retrieving this information
relevant for your meeting this was going
to be information you're going to search
for anyway however in order to issue
that search you would have to say you
know from Paul about some particular
topic and then it turns out we've
exchanged email about a number of things
and you have to find out a way to cut
that down and which email from Paul is
the one I remember and so I've made it
efficient for you to identify sure that
right but when we think about changing
outcome so this is the case you know
where I mentioned the design document
that design document you didn't even
know is relevant you wouldn't have
searched for this if I actually can put
that in front of you and allow you to
ask questions that you wouldn't have
otherwise asked more generally me think
about augmenting capabilities we think
about things like what do our expert
users do how do they interact with the
system how do we take a novice and turn
them into an expert right so you imagine
just starting out your job your fresh
college graduate you're interacting with
visual studio maybe a few other tools
you've been searching around you know
you have your favorite websites for
development that you go to but there's a
wealth of other resources you don't know
when we can connect you with those and
suddenly accelerate your learning curve
as a developer mm-hmm because of the
patterns of other people that really
changes your life it's not just about
efficiency it's about you know changing
what information you have at your hands
based on how you're interacting
[Music]
let's talk now about this project that
you're working on called capers its
calendar aware proactive email
recommender system so tell us about
capers what's new cool different about
it
how does it work who's using it how's it
been received yeah
so in terms of the system itself it's
just this notion that when we look at
how you go throughout life there's a lot
of different meetings that you may have
the typical professional has three or
four meetings a day and one of the
complaints of course is they have too
many meetings but even if we can't just
get rid of their meetings the question
is how can we actually make their
information life better with respect to
their meetings and so part of the things
that we see is that people have trouble
finding information to prepare for a
meeting they have trouble during a
meeting finding information on demand
that they didn't anticipate needing they
have trouble after a meeting referencing
back to things relevant to the meeting
and when we look at meetings we also see
again that there's context right there's
a context of the people that were
involved the topics usually is in the
meeting name the time and so all of us
gives us an idea of when you'll need
this what phase are you in is it before
the meeting you're likely preparing is
it during the meeting and you're really
trying to respond in the second which
means that you might be looking for
different types of information again
it's information you were less likely to
anticipate is it after in which case
you're looking for follow-ups that were
sent out after the time of the meeting
more likely than before and so this
really offers us a capability to
understand the phase the types of
information you want and to predict
those things seamlessly in terms of
where it is right now the Microsoft
search and assistance group is looking
at productizing this this particular
project is being led by abhishek Arun
but he's also working tightly with the
user experience folks in Microsoft
Office and in fast which is a group that
we have in Norway so right now the
system is being used internally by a
small set of people we roll things out
in phases and you get to start seeing
you know how much are your assumptions
right as people interact with things how
often do you need to update the model
because what people need evolves
some of these questions I mentioned in
terms of presentation and selection
biases actually do come up again because
if you have only certain types of
positive information like what was
relevant to this meeting
that's biased by what people search
capabilities were at the time and so
there's a tendency to go just towards
what they currently were able to find
and so being able to expand that set all
of those things come up as you push it
further and further but yes the system
is usable right now and hopefully in the
future we'll have it actually in
customers hands as well and so you've
used it
I've used it yes what's your experience
I mean is it radar ask for you know I
think there's certainly times where I'm
just floud by it where I didn't expect
something and it was there you know
actually the the more amusing thing and
it's a matter of using the feature to I
I had this colleague of mine who's
leading up Abhishek Arun come give a
talk and asked him for the slides that
he presented afterwards and he said why
are you asking me just open up your
meeting and so you know you also have a
how do you change your own habits as
well but even serendipitous cases where
that was something where he had shared
access with me but not sent me the file
but it was there in terms of being
relevant to the context and so those
capabilities where you can well people
those are really fun chances what will
be fascinating for me if I use it as you
can sort through the number of emails
that say quick question or follow-up and
that's the entire subject right there
and I can't remember what I said or what
I was following up on so how you present
content in terms of giving people a
quick summary that is a key challenge
there's you know a part of this that I
haven't talked about that any Ryan White
and Eric Horvitz and I have worked on
with Cortana and again folks in
Microsoft search and assistance the
Cortana suggested reminders where it
looked at your email and said things
that you would take action on in the
future right so you know this is the
kind of case where my wife sends me an
email and says I got the theater tickets
for Saturday night can you get the
babysitter and I respond and say yes
I'll get the babysitter somebody walks
into my office I forget about it
Saturday night comes and didn't get the
babysitter exactly and so if you pop up
a small reminder and say to people hey
it looks like you said you do this do
you need to block out some time or is it
already done just that simple item there
can actually make them take action but
coming back to your question of what
kind of information do you need to give
them you have to give them enough
context where they know what it's about
speaking of that capers is just one
example of where contextual assistance
can come into play where else and with
whom else are you digging around in this
research bin where you say good ideas
and deep research understandings turn
into product ready features yes so I
mentioned kind of the Cortana suggested
reminders is I think another example and
that's tied into this same space of how
we understand how communications relates
to the work you're trying to get done
and that all first key opportunities
will route partner with both other
groups and research I like the language
information technologies group and the
knowledge technologies and experiences
group as well as our product partners to
make those things happen more generally
even going back to old assistants in the
research space like Lumi a that Eric
Orbitz was driving back in I think the
late 90s one of the lessons we learned
is that in order to provide people
assistance you have to be within their
current workflow if your primary
application that you have open and
you're using right now is word then we
need to think about how to integrate
with word and that's part of thinking
about contextual assistance in general
what does it mean to provide assistance
in that moment so other kinds of cases
we're looking at also partnering with
groups in the office as well to look at
applications such as PowerPoint how do
you think about and reuse content across
different types of documents so you
might have different slides that you
need one case how do you refine them and
reuse those later these kind of
opportunities come up in application
after application I mentioned
understanding how people search within
the office suite mm-hmm how do we go
from search directly to actions how do
we recommend those features in general
those come up across the whole different
suite of that what about other verticals
like education or you know these other
big chunks healthcare etc yeah great
question for the most part we haven't
done much of within the group with
health care a little bit education comes
a little bit more closely to things that
we've been looking at so we have
partners in window
an office together with external
partners at Harvey Mudd and the
University of Michigan looking at what
will the reading experiences of the
future look like and in particular how
does information about people's
attention that we can take from things
like gaze tracking or cursor movement
which is a proxy for gaze help us
understand where people's attention are
where they're reading what they're
learning or what they may not be
learning how can we change that reading
experience to enhance their learning and
I think that offers an interesting
capability in general I mean even right
now if you look at teachers again
teachers don't really know what their
students are or not paying attention to
and so this is a case of really thinking
about how can we augment those
capabilities that poll was a perfect
segue into my next topic here which is
as I think about all the data you'll
need to collect about me in order to
anticipate my needs including needs I
don't even know I have and all the ways
you're gonna collect that data my events
my cursor movements my documents my
emails etc I get a little nervous about
what I'm trading off and who's looking
at it in exchange for this amazing
convenience of effortlessly finding my
information so is there anything about
what you do that keeps you up at night I
think that there are a host of different
privacy challenges and the kinds of
methods that we can develop within these
spaces versus what we know is the best
possible just in terms of prediction so
privacy is always foremost in our minds
we don't look at customers data
algorithmically we may run over the data
but how we even generalize from that
data is limited based on privacy
guarantees so you know you think of it
like in terms of the algorithm running
where I learned from your documents
what's important to you mm-hmm
I have to be careful that if I'm gonna
learn about particular words or phrases
that are important to you that I don't
transmit to anyone else indirectly
through the model that those words or
phrases are important to you right and
so even simple cases like imagine that I
knew acquire LinkedIn was a more common
phrase and such as email box that would
be terrible right it doesn't matter even
if was available within Microsoft it
would be terrible and so you know we
think about how do we construct
guarantees on privacy between our
different customers that prevents
anything from going in between
right even indirectly and so yes
absolutely the first thing we do is say
you know we will limit ourselves in
terms of the predictive capabilities to
make sure that we guarantee that first
which is an interesting promise and
perspective so how can you educate users
customers etc that this is actually true
what you're saying it is safe you're not
gonna look at my underpants you know I
think we just have to first off keep
communicating that but then also just be
true to our word not just in what we do
but in who we partner with you know we
work with a lot of external partners we
ask our partners how are you working
with your data who will agree to this
was this a broad enough agreement why
would we work with any partner that
can't meet our own ethics and guidelines
on what we think is acceptable right and
so I think you know being very clear
across the board that this is not just a
subject of policy that we work within
because we've been told but deep beliefs
we hold is foremost
[Music]
tell us a bit about Paul Bennett what's
your background how did you end up
working in information and data Sciences
at Microsoft Research
I started quite a while ago originally
looking first at just philosophical
problems of how we reason about things
and I started was this when you were a
child not far back we got that long ago
but going back to undergrad and I was
actually looking about how do people
reason about court cases so I not only
did philosophy was more from the Thayer
improving side the logical side of
things and so an undergrad I did both
philosophy and a computer science degree
where I looked more at the computer
science side again of doing this and you
know with the computer science part of
the project I mentioned was to actually
build this recommender system as well on
the computer science part of things